Welcome back everyone this is going to be my video
about who is going to take the mantle of the next
black panther during wakanda forever we just got
the first trailer and it reeled a bunch of clues
telling us who it is and how marvel pulls it off a
lot of you also asking if they're ever gonna bring
killmonger back because there's so many big
twists with characters coming back in the mcu
using different methods yes he is in the movie
but not the way that you expect so a version of
killmonger is coming back to the mcu if you're
brand new to the channel she-hulk episode 1 is
starting next week i'll be doing videos for all
the episodes be sure to subscribe to get them
and we're going to be doing a marvel disney plus
giveaway during that all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know in the comments
who you think the new black panther is going to be
but just starting at the beginning in the black
panther wakanda forever trailer they show us a
couple montages of the events of the movie the
trailer scenes are mostly in chronological order
with a few exceptions like there are a couple
of flashbacks to like namor's birth for instance
way earlier in the mcu timeline and they mix and
match a couple different scenes like some of the
scenes are from the same scene just broken up
across a couple different points in the trailer
but mostly they're showing you things in
chronological order how things escalate
to all-out war between wakanda atlantis and namor
and the appearance of this brand new black panther
most marvel movies take place like one right
after the other in the marvel timeline some
take place around the same time but mostly it's
like one right after the other so like doctor
strange multiverse of madness takes place after
spider-man no way home thor love and thunder takes
place after doctor strange two so the present
day of black panther wakanda forever starts after
the events of thor love and thunder maybe not
that long after but a little bit after at least
and according to taika watiti in marvel thor 11th
thunder is meant to take place about three years
after avengers end game so wakanda forever
is mostly around three to four years after
avengers end game which is about how much time
has passed in real life just in terms of years
after avengers end game was released in theaters
they begin the trailer with a funeral procession
for t'challa the reason they're all wearing white
is because in some cultures around the world
in this area of africa that wakanda comes from
people wear white to funerals instead of black
that's more like a european and american thing
the reason why they're performing this large
dance like they're celebrating but everyone has
this mixture of happy and sad faces is because per
their customs the funeral is meant to celebrate
his life so they're celebrating his memory but
that's why shuri is so sad because she lost her
brother i believe the way they're explaining him
passing away isn't like some crazy assassination
from namor in the comics or anything like that i
think he's meant to die from a long illness after
this you eventually see a team of researchers in
the deep sea diving gear they're heading into the
ocean looking for vibranium deposits underwater
that's why you see them invading this facility
in wakanda later in the trailer while they're
doing this earlier in the movie though they wind
up discovering atlantis by accident which is why
namor gets pissed off because it was supposed to
be hidden like wakanda was hidden from the rest of
the world this whole time this is where we get to
the ironheart riri williams plot why she's such a
big part of the movie riri williams is supposed to
have designed the deep sea diving gear that allows
them to survive those lower depths because
the diving suits here are built kind of like
derivatives of iron man armor suits like the same
type of technology that she uses to build her iron
heart suits she builds her own super advanced
armor suits it makes sense that's how she earns
money for herself on the side by contracting with
them like we will pay you a giant dump truck of
money if you design us some armor suits that
will allow us to look at the bottom of the ocean
this is where we get to the doctor doom doom war
plot stuff and i believe he's only going to be
referenced very lightly in the movie like he's not
a big character in the movie or anything like that
like maybe at the end like a post credit scene or
something like that we'll tease that doctor doom
was kind of pulling the strings from behind but
he's supposed to be the person in the mcu who's
funding this research looking for more vibranium
so he's the person who's effectively paying riru
williams using a bunch of different sources to
hide his identity in the comic book version of
doom war he just outright invades wakanda trying
to steal their vibranium kind of like ulysses claw
he basically wants to use that to upgrade
his armor all of his doombots all this
technology like the way they explain in the
mcu vibranium has a billion different uses
so of course everybody wants vibranium then i
believe what we're witnessing in the trailer
is namor and the atlanteans going after riri
williams in the cambridge area like that's why
you see atlanteans in cambridge here because they
find out from all the tech that she's the person
who built all that so he blames her they want
to kill her to prevent her from doing that again
and i believe that is sherry and akoye who
find out the source of all this and go to
protect her from the atlanteans and that's why
namor thinks that wakanda was really behind
all this endeavor leading to this escalating
to all-out war between wakanda and atlantis
when he attacks wakanda flooding the throne room
here like this is meant to be sure he trapped in
the throne room here with water surrounding
it with the entire building burning down
later in the trailer raimonda seems super pissed
off while she's addressing the united nations
but then also in a meeting with her tribe leaders
she starts shouting about how her entire family
is dead making you wonder what happened to shuri
like why is she saying her entire family is dead
does that mean that shuri also died during the
movie i think this is marvel just being a little
misleading with the way they cut the trailer
like they want you to think that shuri was killed
by namor too or at least ramonda believes that
shorty was killed by naymore but she's still alive
then after you see this all-out battle between
the forces of wakanda like umbaku trying to attack
namor like everybody just going crazy things
escalate to this scorched earth policy because
ramada just goes on the war path you see the brand
new black panther enter frame fighting namor on
the beach head here near wakanda is someone has
taken the mantle so a lot of people wondering like
who is this is this nakia is this shuri is this
a version of killmonger coming back but here's
the thing in order to become the new black panther
at least per the rules in the mcu that they've set
up is a little bit different from the comic book
methods you need a couple things to do that in the
mcu and currently the most important one that's
missing or unavailable is the heart-shaped herb
killmonger burnt all of it when he became king
and used it to give himself black panther powers
the heart-shaped herb also has another important
function it gives the user the ability to transfer
their consciousness to the alternate dimension of
the ancestral plane that's how they communicate
with their fellow dead ancestors and recently
deceased in the movie i believe that shuri is
trying to find a technological workaround
replacement for the heart-shaped like they
have the molecular structure of the heart-shaped
stored in their database and she tries to recreate
an artificial version so that they can empower
a new black panther because wakanda must have
a black panther supposedly she is supposed to try
it on herself hoping to speak with her brother
t'challa on the ancestral plane get his help
in becoming another black panther but instead
something goes wrong because it's not the real
heart-shaped herb and she winds up contacting
killmonger instead in the ancestral plain and
that's how they bring a version of killmonger back
it's still the same killmonger he's still dead
it's just that he's inside the ancestral plane
and killmonger winds up helping shuri become
the next black panther giving her advice like a
slightly more hardcore version because killmonger
was so militaristic compared to t'challa and
because marvel and kevin feige is that they're not
going to do like a crazy artificial carrie fisher
type of version of chadwick boseman t'challa so
like they're not gonna artificially recreate him
in the movie for a scene where he talks to her in
the ancestral plane that's why they're bringing
killmonger back because they're not gonna do force
ghost version of t'challa so effectively shuri
becomes the next black panther and the reason
why her new black panther suit has all these gold
highlights on it that you see in the trailer is
way more flashy than t'challa's black panther suit
it's just because it's more to her personal style
taste like everything she wears every time you see
her wearing an outfit it is like the flashiest
most stylistic thing that you've ever seen
in all the gold highlights are also a reference
to killmonger's crazy golden jaguar version of the
black panther suit he was all about the showiness
of the bright gold highlights over the suit too
so if he is training her to become the next
black panther it also makes sense that some
of the gold is inspired by him as well they
also recently just released some lego sets
for the movie and even though you have to kind of
take it with a grain of salt because it's never
a one-to-one comparison you see a version
of shuri here with her panther hands weapons
wearing a new black panther suit for all the
people who thought the new black panther would
be nakia i believe her arc in the movie she is
like a really big character is that she actually
had a relationship with t'challa like they kind
of set that up at the first black panther movie
even though he got snapped during the
five year time jump he would have been
back in the mcu for at least about three plus
years i believe during the events of the movie
they're going to explain that enough time had
passed after avengers endgame before his death
that she got pregnant with his child at some point
and eventually she'll give birth to his son and
that son will become the next black panther when
he comes of age in the comics most people remember
black panther had a son named azari with storm but
because chadwick boseman passed away before storm
was introduced in the mcu they can't really do a
version of that relationship so i don't know what
their long-term plans are for t'challa's future
son they could always age him up quickly in the
next five to eight years and put him on a young
avengers team like azari was or use some time
travel trickery to explain how a virgin from the
future who's much older comes back into the past
but there will be a black panther three like
they are going to do a third movie in the trilogy
they'd probably wait to show him on screen or like
really talk about him in great detail until we get
to that movie but going forward in the mcu if
shuri becomes the new black panther i believe
they're also planning on splitting the roles in
wakanda too so normally what happens is you pass
the mantle of black panther to whoever is going
to become the next king of wakanda but i believe
they're splitting the roles so that surety becomes
the new black panther and henceforth will just
cross over with avengers 5 kane dynasty avengers
6 secret wars and just have adventures with them
traveling all over the world in umbaku is going
to become the next king of wakanda after raimonda
also the whole idea of shuri becoming black
panther is just them doing the comics too
like t'challa passed the mantle to her he was
still alive at the point but he went into exile
he passed the mantle to shuri for a brief period
before he came back and took back the mantle but
everyone post all your theories in the comments
what do you think they're gonna do with the next
version of the black panther what do you think
they're gonna do with doctor doom in the future
of the mcu and what do you think they're gonna
do in black panther 3 the movie is coming out
in november so we're probably gonna get another
trailer pretty soon too there's a big disney plus
day that's happening in september where marvel is
going to show off a bunch of trailers for all the
upcoming disney plus series just like last year
like it'll be a trailer fest of course they'll do
videos for all the stuff that they drop we'll also
get a bunch of star wars disney plus trailers too
so we'll probably get the first mandalorian season
3 trailer during that as well they did show off
the trailer video for that a little while ago you
can click here to watch my mandalorian season 3
trailer video in easter eggs and click here for my
full black panther wakanda forever trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!